Russia called the meeting of the
security Council saying US air strikes
in Syria and Iraq over the weekend risk
escalating War throughout the Middle
East a threat to International Peace and
security recent events confirmed that
the US is not looking for or has never
sought a solution to the problems in the
region but the US accused Russia of
calling the meeting under false
pretenses the actions US forces took on
February 2 are necessary and
proportionate consistent with
international law and in exercise of the
United States inherent right to
self-defense the US bombed 85 Targets in
retaliation for the deaths of three of
its military personnel stationed in
Jordan it accused the Islamic resistance
in Iraq a coalition of Iraqi militias
aligned with Iran Iran has denied any
involvement in that attack some Security
Council Members like the UK K said the
US has a right to defend itself but all
said they are worried about a wider war
in the region un officials have also
expressed concern about a widening war
in the Middle East as well as a
worsening humanitarian situation in Gaza
there the largest Aid operation unra is
itself under attack the Secretary
General announced an independent
committee to review UNR make sure it's
doing everything in its power to ensure
neutrality that's after accusations 12
of its employees helped Hamas on October
7th leading several Nations to suspend
their funding we hope that uh donors uh
have taken clear notice of the Swift
action taken by the Secretary General
taken by the commissioner General to
address
head-on uh issues uh that may exist uh
we will continue uh to communicate with
donors they are looking for new donors
to meet gaza's growing needs Kristen
salumi Al jazer the United
Nations make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer